hey what's up my name is samuel leeds in
this video i want to talk about
capital gains tax and how the government
are
increasing property tax when you are
selling your home
now i think that they are lying
basically about what's going to happen
about why it's going to happen
about the effect of what that's going to
be and in this video i'm going to talk
about
my opinion okay this is not tax advice
this is my opinion
about property tax capital gain tax and
how the government and the media
are controlling the narrative and are
trying to
manufacture something from this so this
is my opinion that's my disclaimer
speak to an accountant about how this
might affect you if you're a property
investor
here's how i think it's gonna affect me
i think it's gonna affect me very very
very very very
little okay and the newspaper headlines
is like
capital gains tax for property investors
could
double could double and then everyone's
thinking ah you know
taxes are gonna double for property
investors oh no but here's the thing
right
firstly let me talk about capital gains
tax
capital gains tax is when you buy a
house
and then the property gains in value
and then you sell the house that profit
that you made
the tax that you pay is called capital
gains tax and they
that we don't know the details but i
think they're saying january time
they're going to be announcing it but
january they're going to be announcing
what the new changes are but they're
predicting that capital gains
tax could double everyone's freaking out
the newspapers are freaking out my
property youtube friends
are all freaking out saying the same
thing my thoughts are this firstly
if you're buying a property in a company
like i do with the intention just let's
say
but you buy a piece of land in a company
you build
and then you sell those houses you don't
pay capital gains
tax you pay income tax so
if capital gains tax goes up it doesn't
matter
if you buy a house and then the value
goes up
you don't sell it anyway you refinance
it
so this capital gains tax thing really
in my opinion is only really going to
affect amateur
landlords who don't really know what
they're doing that buy a house
maybe they have a couple houses and then
after a few years they're like oh i've
made some
equity and then they sell they pay
capital gains tax
if you're doing the buy refurbished
refinance strategy guess what you pay
zero capital gains tax because
you don't pay tax on debt so when
property when
the value of a property goes up you're
refinancing it
now you might sell it if you're if
you're buying it to sell it but if you
buy to sell
you know limited company you don't pay
capital gains tax anyway
so nearly all of the strategies that i'm
teaching uh
renter rents lease option agreements
deal packaging
buying land to sell it buy refurbished
refinance buying a property turning into
a hmo
renting it out like all of these
strategies capital gains tax doesn't
really come into it
so i'm not worried at all about this
also the people that make the rules and
the same people that make money in
property
so whenever they do this they do this
with section 24 they brought in section
24 which was a massive
tax pain in the bum for landlords
everyone was freaking out but then they
said oh but not for the big boys
not for the people that are buying in a
company if you buy for a company it
doesn't apply
this is for the amateurs now yeah for
sure i'm sure the government are going
to increase taxes
i'm sure because they've given out loads
of loans and furlough
i'm sure they want to recoup some of
that money but the people that are going
to get hit by this
probably aren't going to be the smart
wealthy successful people because
they're the people that make the rules
up anyway
i don't think this will affect property
developers hardly at all i think that
this is going to affect
the amateurs the oh i've got an
accidental i'm an accidental landlord
i'm selling to release some funds those
people are going to be affected that's
generally the case
so i'm not personally worried whenever
there's a rule change over here for bad
there's a real change over here for good
now question why are people going crazy
about this
they're going crazy about this because
the media were talking about it a lot
and because the media were talking about
it a lot everyone on youtube is talking
about everyone's talking about it but
this is my
theory now catch this okay this is my
theory
i think that they are deliberately
scare-mongering and the reason they're
doing that is because
everyone's thinking oh my goodness
capital gains tax is gonna
double january next year so everyone now
is wanting to sell their house if
they've got properties they're saying
let's sell it quickly let's sell it
quickly before the capital gains tax
comes in next year
if it does okay so the reason they're
doing that i think is because they're
trying to
it's all part of this trying to boost
the the property economy it's trying to
lift up house prices and stuff like they
brought in the stamp duty holiday
and these different things to
incentivize buyers
if you're in the property market you'll
know this is the case this is not my
opinion right now this is fact because i
know the property market
well okay i've been doing a lot of
property deals recently my students have
been in a lot of property deals recently
and if you're doing property deals
you'll know this is the case
are there at the moment more buyers or
more sellers and the answer is there are
more buyers
people are queuing up to buy properties
there's not enough properties
there's not enough properties at the
moment so i think what they're trying to
do in this narrative
is they're trying to get more properties
for sale
they're trying to get more properties
for sale the media are doing this like
crazy so they're saying
yeah sell your house sell your house
sell your house it's a great time to
sell
capital gains taxes get a double sell it
now quickly
and at the same time they're saying
buy a house now buy a house now stamp
duty holiday stamp duty holiday buy now
buy now buy now
they're they're locked everything down
but they've not locked down the property
market
because i think what they're trying to
do is they're just trying to encourage
transactions
why do the government care about
transactions happening right now within
the property market
well it's because they need money
because they've given all this furlough
money
and they're trying to recoup it and they
know that if houses are selling
now fast if there's lots of houses
selling they're going to get paid as a
result of that
you know you might think how do they get
paid i mean come on they get paid every
time a house sells they don't just get
paid once
when you buy a house you have to pay
stamp duty tax
so every time someone buys a house that
person's having to pay
tax just for buying the house and then
the sellers having to pay tax as well
so that that one transaction the
seller's paying tax the buyers paying
tax
everyone's paying tax what are the
government doing well nothing they're
just encouraging transactions to happen
so that they can get more tax tax tax
tax so when you can see
what they're doing and why it's
happening you don't have to freak out
don't freak out just get educated that's
my advice i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did smash the like button
if you've got questions by the way i
will do a follow-up video about this
tax questions about the implications of
this what is capital gains tax exactly
you know um anything tax related comment
below
and i'll do another video at some point
and i'll try my best
to help comment below subscribe
smash the like button i'll see you
tomorrow